eat at all
[Music]
[Applause]
he everybody is Charlie we got brand-new
Dragonball super bro Li movie footage to
break down they finally canonized Gogeta
with a few minor changes from Dragon
Ball Z fusion reborn in the Dragon Ball
GT series the second part of the trailer
takes you through all their
transformations in their different
fights with that Blizzard theme song
we're doing a new round of that imax
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about Gogeta on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this the
biggest changes a lot of you probably
notice is is that they won obviously the
canonizing Gogeta which is a big thing
because previously all the original
appearances were in non-canonical movies
or TV series first time they form Gogeta
was during Dragon Ball Z fusion reborn
and then again during the Dragon Ball GT
series the other big change is that it
doesn't seem like they're using Patara
earrings to form Gogeta
they're forming the fusion the same way
that Goten and Trunks formed go tanks
that changed the original orange padding
on his vest to yellow it does look a
little bit more like go tents jacket
they've also changed some of his facial
features and his skin tones to make him
look a little bit more like Vegeta
instead of Goku at the beginning of the
trailer you see them with the black hair
black hair is always what they have at
base power level they went above and
beyond to make the colors pop a little
bit more so I think they're paying a
little extra attention to the
transformations and their hair colors
that correspond to each of those levels
but the really cool stacking bonus holy
crap moment in the trailer isn't that
not only do they form Gogeta but they
also go super saiyan blue while in
Gogeta form if they're canonizing all
this old stuff i don't know if they're
gonna incorporate any kind of version of
Super Saiyan 4 of they'll just skip it
because they're already both going super
saiyan blue which is supposed to be a
level above Super Saiyan God and the
whole thing about Super Saiyan God mode
/ the opening arc of Dragon Ball super
is that at SSG level goku strikes
against beerus threatened to destroy the
universe so if they're already going a
level above that then i don't see any
point in doing Super Saiyan 4 and the
whole point of Gogeta
to begin with was that originally goku
and vegeta both went super saiyan 4 and
the two of them separately in that form
weren't enough to defeat omega shenron
so they had to combine their power thus
the goji diffusion was born so I'm just
assuming it's the same basic scenario in
the dry
boss super burly movie except it's both
of them in Super Saiyan blue form at the
same time not being able to take Broly a
lot of you can probably sense where
they're going with this just based on
the trailer footage we've seen so far
and the fact that Gogeta seems like such
a badass and they're trying to high
Broly up is the most powerful person
ever most of you will note that even
though it's not Canon Goku and Vegeta
have never been defeated while in Gogeta
form so it seems like in the movie
what's gonna happen is as they ascend to
one of their ultimate fusion forms Super
Saiyan blue Gogeta and Broly still kicks
their ass like you see the progression
of escalation of forms as they go
between super saiyan Super Saiyan God
Super Saiyan blue and then they form the
fusion it seems like bro Lee will also
be leveling out to match like oh you're
making me matter and matter so he
ascends through forms until finally
after they go super saiyan blue Gogeta
he goes legendary super saiyan then that
becomes the ultimate throwdown because i
don't know what will be beyond super
saiyan blue Gogeta but you guys couldn't
let me know in the comments what would
be more powerful in their form the
people working on the movie have implied
that they won't be using ultra instinct
so we'll see about that
but here's the other thing to consider
we've seen Broly fighting Wiese in the
other trailers i've seen a lot of people
wondering if maybe bro lee will either
become a future god of destruction or
some similar level of authority on a
galactic scale because they've been
teasing this next Dragonball Ark with
the manga and other villains in Broly
being a continuing presence in the
Dragon Ball universe like he'll come
back as a character after all this is
done but it causes a lot of story
problems if you want to have him pal
around with all the regular characters
because how do you find credible threats
for the most powerful being in the
universe if he's able to take on someone
like Wiese like it just doesn't make a
lot of sense unless you depowered him
after the movie now he does have the
control collar early in the movie but
pretty clearly that comes off at a
certain point and that's when things
really start to go crazy but the rest of
the trailer footage is that blizzard
music video with the theme song just
taking you through all the different
angles of their fights in a linear
progression of their forms so you have
goku and vegeta fighting Broly in super
sand then unless they cut out a whole
bunch of footage it seems like both of
them jump straight to super saiyan god
mode then they both jump to super saiyan
blue mode and then just as they're both
firing here it seems like some time
after this moment is when they form
Gogeta what they might do to
with broglie's classic legendary Super
Saiyan form is like they all level up to
their final ultimate power forms is just
retune it a little bit to let you know
that it's more powerful than Super
Saiyan blue Gogeta form they also show a
whole bunch more footage of Shenron
Frieza and some of the other characters
so you see Frieza showing up with bro
Lee and his father on their special
Frieza for ship this is earlier in the
movie the reason they come to Planet
Earth this is on planet Earth in this
Arctic area is because they're looking
for the dragon balls because Frieza
wants them then they start their fight
then later you see Frieza co2 golden
Frieza form and start attacking
broglie's so at some point they have
their falling out most of the trailer
footage so far has just focused on Goku
and Vegeta fighting Broly
but obviously Frieza is still a big part
of this - you also see a little bit of
boma you see a little bit of wheeze you
see some beerus if beerus does not throw
down with Broly at some point during the
movie it'll be interesting to see what
his excuses because even though he's a
god of destruction one of the most
powerful beings in the universe one of
his secret abilities is making up
excuses for not doing work because even
though Broly and his father hate vegeta
for his father King Vegeta banishing
them from the planet if they were to
find out that beerus not Frieza was
ultimately responsible for the
destruction of their planet then that
would give Broly a really compelling
reason to want to kill Frieza and beerus
but here's my other big question for you
guys do you think that beerus is going
to fight Broly during the movie if you
didn't see on my Twitter a little while
ago - the really cool thing that
happened in real life is that they
invited me to the u.s. premiere of the
movie so I'll be able to do an early
review in a couple weeks it'll be non
spoilery so no worries we can wait to do
a spoiler review till after everybody
around the world has seen the movie
because some people will be seeing it
before others but I'll say
congratulations Thomas Pope you're the
giveaway winner from my last big
Dragonball video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here to
rewatch the final Dragon Ball super
Broly trailer and click here for a brand
new Avengers 4 teaser video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]